tonight yes my mum and I are actually
gonna go head to head with our Apple
puddings and you know all about my
campaign about getting women back in the
kitchen well the first woman I ever saw
in the kitchen was my mum and for some
bizarre reason yes against my 21 years
experience in a professional kitchen she
still reckons that her apple pudding is
better than mine just a women's thing a
woman's thing well I'm gonna wish you
good luck because I think you're gonna
need it how long does it take 20 minutes
20 minutes I'll see you in the oven
right okay good luck and no spying right
mum how are you doing you are Mr Ramsay
bring it over here please yes thanks to
mine
do you know what mum I've got a really
good feeling about this one you know
that well for me no no but for me yeah
honestly I think for me look at the
difference and this is payback time for
all that gray lamb you served me for
those years
truth
okay
[Applause]
okay there you go good luck good luck I
think you're gonna need it no I think
you'll need it okay wait wait wait none
there's mine now again I have to say
presentation wise yeah
yours looks nice but it doesn't blow me
away however is that cooked in the
middle yeah
no oh [__] no it's not actually all
right it's my ass uh two minutes please
how did you know that wasn't cooked in
the middle for my angle you could see it
sinking in the middle Titanic
right
they're all [__] burn
have we got any sea bass left because
Iron Man all right come around here you
yep yeah
he's Burnt Tree pants from now you burnt
it we started with 75 portions of bass
we've got half a dining room not served
yet we've [__] so many bass so early
we've run out I'm gonna finish some more
Bass But when I fill it these bad when
we get them can we [__] cook them
properly Richard yeah sure yes hello
quickest and portions here listen to me
on top of 75 just under 100 portions of
bass hello don't [__] it it's bad okay
John but this yes take the egg sandwich
upstairs and take my bread and butter
pudding alongside it please yes yeah and
make sure you've got some sick bags for
the sandwich there is one winner of
course there's one winner and the winner
is
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they found mine too heavy yes indeed
it can't be true
I'm afraid it is Gordon
you know when you go outside this door
you turn left by the traffic lights yeah
it's called a job center yeah
right I'm gonna ask you an honest
question now yeah look at those molds
and tell me you're happy for that I'm
not happy no nor am I you want me to
check them back to him again I'm asking
you are you happy with them no I'm not
happy with them would you pay for them
no no one [__] I well the five people
who are getting them I'll pay their
[__] bill all right Adrian yes sir if
you thought you're coming in this
restaurant to run it with your standards
didn't even bother coming I'm running it
with my standards because whether you
like it or not it's my reputation on the
line yes end the [__] story yes yeah
thank you chef you finish them off
you're [__] speaking to me okay
you'll finish them off it's been nice so
you're going home what do you want me to
say Well done for [__] them I don't
want your [__] I want you to say
something once Mr Ramsey and then shut
the [__] up oh what do you mean shut the
just tell me once you're not happy and
then leave me alone do me a favor get
out and cool down take some [__]
fresh air and have a big think thank you
okay now
well I'm not going to [__] Bolton for
holiday that's for sure they like both
of them first I'll get it this is good
however there is one winner one clear
winner one clear clear winner yeah there
wasn't okay I put down one clear winner
shut up
yours is a bit too much no they find
diamond one very authentic very Harish
authentic yeah beef in it yeah
I just lift it up a little bit you
fondled my [__] now you beat me in the
[__] challenge we do me a favor yeah
[__] off my kitchen yes oh my God all
right on order four covers table five
four squid for chicken Valentine four
Crepes Suzette
thank you to each side no no no are you
telling them what to do or should I tell
them what to do you should tell them
thank you so shut the [__] up then right
we'll do uh Peter my presentation's crap
no no listen to me listen listen listen
please
there's no garlic in your bok choy
and there's no chili there was I put
some chili in where is it then
you're not here to argue there's nothing
in there start again I'm going to be
going to the [__] mental home in a
minute any chance of going quicker
otherwise I'll get them to put a sign up
average waiting time for Peter's table
45 minutes join the queue
what is that no huh what have you manage
that I don't know sound like a plastic
container in there get them out yeah do
you start off with a clean pan I did you
sure I was thought I thought I did I may
be wrong I don't think you did you
started cooking a dirty pan anyway Peter
yeah let's get it in the bin and start
again yes everyone's laughing and [__]
around let me just show you something
hello look there you go yeah that's just
come back
right now right now you're all making
yourself look [__] stupid okay so hey
I know no no don't Chef me no no yeah
because I didn't have nowhere to put the
other twice listen listen don't serve
black Madeleine's end of story okay Chef
that was a mishap all the others if you
look I'll put them in the [__] bin I
missed one so come back as I said I
missed one every other Magdalene that's
burned is in the bin I threw him in
there
just sent it back no I'm not arguing I'm
apologizing because because I thought
that's the standard of your apology
hello hey
sorry chef
I am sorry [__]
taste that Kerry and tell me the first
thing you taste in your mouth it's quick
[Music]
egg it's burnt
you can't taste that's burnt yeah I can
get it in the bin let's go okay Rebecca
yeah what is that I know no no no no no
no no no no sorry
um really I know okay sorry
um
get it in the bin and start again
[Music]
it's Perry yes bring them here they've
done as well show me lift the pan up
what are we doing
come here come here come here come here
ladies ladies Kerry we've been cooking
now for 20 minutes yeah and fuckles
happened I'm not here for five hours and
all the customers you know that before I
met you guys at least thought that you
could [__] cook scrambled eggs try
Nicola something
ladies hey ladies
oh [__] me Ali JB well so this week the
winner is yes
we're done Sarah I'll get out
pissing around oh no one yes okay again
really sorry the result you know that
I'm gonna go upstairs and see the judges
when are they
yeah I'm glad you find it funny um
it's interesting I mean taste that again
for me
yeah all of you and then I can start
with
the lady at the end now
tell me what you would
tasting it tastes bitter bitter yeah
it's quite kind of like almost burnt
taste to it burnt
look out look at just look how wet that
is in the center in the middle but
you've got to get through the dry
outside to get to the middle
like I don't you know I don't understand
it just slightly too
sorry all three of you can off out of
here now as well yes there oh dear
useless I'm not gonna serve it I'm gonna
serve my chocolate brownie my restaurant
my customers and and my reputation on
the line that's that Susie
I'm so sorry darling were you sleeping
no you weren't um it's called Ramsay
here just calling from the f word
kitchen and Russell's had the most
amazing day
um there's something there's something
there's something he's been dying to ask
you
um and um it's taken this moment to
realize that he's been wasting time for
the last five years okay right Russell I
want you to shout down the phone to your
beloved Susie
soz can you hear me I'm here I can hear
you so I'm on my knee actually at the
moment
assistant
will you marry me
no go for it
so so I'm not joking I'm seeing I'm
standing here all the lads are behind me
please say yes Golden's dragged out and
he said it's not far too long now please
say yes
as soon as you marry me
what happened there I know it's called
the f word but when it's brown it's
cooked
um
pubic hair though can you just get rid
of that sorry yeah
but look at that you smell that ammonia
in there yeah it's a little bit there
isn't it all right I see you're on the
verge of killing someone I wasn't trying
to kill him although that would have
made the headlines I would have become
famous that way uh the guy who saw off
Gordon Ramsay I'm a vegan I've been a
vegan for 20 years you're a vegan yes me
how can you call yourself a chef you
don't cook fish or meat well I work in
vegetarian restaurants
and what is it um this is a Cory tofu
with a tofu yogurt sorry
someone's toast is burning toast is
burning
let me set an alarm on that [__]
Grill yes come on lady wakey wakey you
may eat [__] burnt toast up North but
we're in [__] London
I know that voice like having four genus
three quarters of the kids yes they're
burnt so it's gonna be all right yeah
when they burst that egg yo we want the
egg yolk the richness running all over
the piece right well done very very nice
indeed go please yes 14. let's go
first
[Music]
thing again
let's [__] argue okay yeah and for
the last three hours yeah you've been
calling me mate
okay sorry he's a parent why are you so
[__] chippy I'm not chipping right
Gordon Gordon James I'd be greatly
appreciated for the next 20 minutes
Gordon I'm not your [__] mate okay
foreign